Ha ha, ha, ich bin so witzig.
Ein Dislike - waaas?!
*Musik*
Unter der "Dunklen Triade"
versteht man in der Psychologie
Narzissmus,
Psychopathie und Machiavellismus.
Drei sozialschädliche Eigenschaften,
die nicht selten zusammen auftreten.
Während die Dunkle Triade vor allem
bei Menschen in Machtpositionen
besonders ausgeprägt sein soll,
gehen Psychologen davon aus,
dass diese drei dunklen
Charaktereigenschaften
in jedem von uns stecken.
(flüstert) In jedem von uns.
Fragt sich nur in welchem Maß?
Heute beginnen wir mit Teil 1 dieser
3-teiligen Serie und zwar mit:
Ob Donald Trump oder Kylie Jenner,
narzisstische -
also selbst verliebte -
Menschen springen uns tagtäglich
aus dem Fernsehen
oder dem Handy entgegen.
Look at me!
Und als jemand, der gern vor
der Kamera steht, muss auch ich
von einem überdurchschnittlich
ausgeprägtem Narzissmus ausgehen.
Oh hi! Look at me!
Aber was heißt Narzissmus
eigentlich genau?
Bei Narzissmus unterscheidet
man zwischen normalem,
nicht pathologischen, Narzissmus
als Charaktereigenschaft
und einer narzisstischen
Persönlichkeitsstörung,
die ganz offiziell im
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual
of Mental
Disorders aufgeführt ist.
Zeichen, dass du an einer
narzisstischen
Persönlichkeitsstörung leidet:
Du wirkst auf deine Mitmenschen
arrogant, überheblich
und angeberisch.
Naja, aber schließlich bist du auch
anderen Menschen überlegen.
Davon bist du überzeugt.
Du fühlst dich "enttitled",
wie man im Englischen sagen würde,
d.h. du wirst wütend
oder ungeduldig wenn man dich
nicht als den besonders
besonderen Menschen behandelt,
der du bist.
Du übertreibst
bei deinen Leistungen und Talenten
und bestehst darauf,
von allem das Beste zu haben.
Die besten Noten,
das beste Auto, die beste Frau.
Gleichzeitig tust du dich
wirklich schwer mit Kritik.
Insgeheim belasten
dich deine Unsicherheit,
Scham und Verletzlichkeit.
Auf Kritik reagiert du deswegen
oft mit Wut oder Verachtung
und neigt dazu,
deine Kritiker schlecht zu machen,
um deine Überlegenheit
nicht zu gefährden.
Trotz sozialer Unverträglichkeit
strahlen Menschen mit ausgeprägter
Dunkler Triade nicht selten
eine gewisse Anziehungskraft aus.
Es ist z.B nachgewiesen,
dass Narzissten oft einen besseren
1. Eindruck hinterlassen, wenn sie
sich neuen Menschen vorstellen.
Durch attraktivere Körpersprache,
Mimik und, nicht selten,
bessere Kleidung.
Hi, ich find mich selbst so klasse,
dass du es auch glaubst.
Außerdem fanden
Wissenschaftler heraus,
dass Narzissten im Schnitt
mehr verdienen.
Auch wenn Nazismus
nicht in Verbindung
mit Führungspositionen steht,
da spielen Psychopathie
und Machiavellismus
eine größere Rolle.
Wie ausgeprägt
ist eure Dunkle Triade?
Das könnt ihr raus finden
mit einem kleinen Quiz,
das die BBC in Zusammenarbeit
mit Wissenschaftlern erstellt hat.
Verlinke ich euch unten.
Das da,
sind übrigens meine Ergebnisse.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017).
So viel zu Teil 1.
Jeweils ein Video zu Psychopathie
und Machiavellismus
folgen dann demnächst
hier bei "schönschlau".
Schreibt doch mal in die Kommentare
welche der Dunklen Triade
bei euch am meisten ausgeprägt ist
und abonniert mich bitte,
denn wie ihr gesehen habt,
bin ich narzisstisch veranlagt
und ich brauche eure Anerkennung.